Y에 저장된 어떤 고전적 상태든
qubit X에 XOR된다고 상상할 수 있어요.
명확성을 위해, 여기 이 gate가
표준 기저 상태에 미치는 작용을 보여주는 다이어그램이 있어요.
A와 B가 이진 값이라고
가정해요.
다른 상태에 대한 작용은
항상 그렇듯이 선형성에 의해 결정돼요.
더 진행하기 전에, 이런 quantum circuit 다이어그램에서
qubit의 순서에 관해 따를 규약을 명시적으로 설명하는 것이 도움이 될 거예요.
이것과 같은 quantum circuit 다이어그램에서요.
규약은 quantum circuit 다이어그램에서
아래에서 위로의 순서가 튜플이나 텐서 곱에서의
왼쪽에서 오른쪽 순서와 동일하다는 거예요.
마치 튜플이나 텐서 곱에서처럼요.
이것은 시리즈에서 따를 규약이고
Qiskit에서도 사용되는 규약이에요.
이 특정 circuit의 경우, qubit 쌍
X, Y에 작용하는 것으로 생각하고 있어요.
X가 먼저 오는 이유는 아래에 있기 때문이고, Y가 마지막(이 경우 두 번째)으로 오는 이유는 위에 있기 때문이에요.
도움이 된다면 이것을 시각적으로 생각하는
방법은, 이 circuit을 시계 방향으로 회전시켜서
입력이 위에 오고
출력이 아래에 오도록 상상하면
qubit의 순서가 맞게 돼요.
이 순서 때문에 헷갈리는 경우가 있으니,
이 규약을 잘 기억해 두세요.
이 circuit이 설명하는 작용을 생각해 보면, 먼저
Y에 Hadamard gate가 적용되고
그다음 두 qubit에 Controlled NOT
gate가 적용되는데, Y가 제어이고
X가 대상이에요.
이 두 gate의 결합된 작용을 설명하는
유니터리 행렬을 적어보고 싶다면 그렇게 할 수 있어요.
먼저 Y에 대한 Hadamard gate를 고려해요.
Y에 Hadamard gate를 적용하고 X에는 아무것도 하지 않는데,
이것은 X에 항등 연산을 수행하는 것과 같아요.
그래서 두 qubit 전체에 대한 Hadamard gate의 작용은
항등 행렬과 Hadamard 연산을
나타내는 행렬의 텐서 곱으로 주어져요.
Y에 대한 Hadamard 연산이에요.
이렇게 생겼는데, X가 먼저 오고
Y가 두 번째라는 규약을 기억하세요.
그래서 항등 행렬과 H의 텐서 곱이에요.
그다음 Controlled NOT 연산을
적용하는데, 이 행렬 표현을 가지고 있고, 이것도 우리 규약과 일치해요.
두 번째 qubit Y가 제어이고 첫 번째 qubit X가 대상이에요.
영상을 멈추고 이것이 맞는지 확인하는 것을 두려워하지 마세요. 그리고 이 점에 대해 더 이상 상기시키지 않을게요.
이 영상들을 일시 정지하고, 원하는 만큼 여러 번 돌려보고,
원하면 재생 속도를 조절하고,
자신에게 가장 잘 맞는 방식으로 사용할 수 있어요.
어쨌든, 두 연산을 합성하면
결합된 작용은 여기 이 곱으로 설명돼요.
이 두 행렬이 이 순서로 곱해지는 이유는
Hadamard가 먼저 수행되고 Controlled NOT이
두 번째로 수행되기 때문이에요.
다시 한번, 이것은 수업 1에서 이야기한 것과
일치하는데, 순서가 본질적으로
뒤집힌다는 거예요.
행렬 곱셈을 수행하면 여기 이 행렬을 얻어요.
그리고 이 행렬에서 circuit이 표준 기저 상태에
대해 무엇을 하는지 읽어낼 수 있어요.
입력 0, 0에 대해 circuit을 실행하면, 즉 첫 번째 qubit이 Ket 0이고 두 번째 qubit이 Ket 0이면,
결과는 Phi+ Bell 상태인데,
행렬의 첫 번째 열에서 볼 수 있어요.
0, 1을 넣으면 Phi- 상태를 얻고, 1, 0은 Psi+ 상태를 줘요.
그리고 1, 1은 Psi-가 아니라 -1 곱하기 Psi-를 줘요.
마이너스 부호는 여기서 별로
중요하지 않아요. 이것을 없애고 싶으면
두 qubit에 스왑 연산을 수행하면 되고
처음 세 표준 기저 상태에 일어난 일을
망치지 않을 거예요.
하지만 이 예시에서는
정말 중요하지 않아요.
요약하면, circuit은 표준 기저 상태에 대해 여기 이런 작용을 해요.
특정 circuit이 무엇을 하는지
생각할 때, 행렬로 변환해서
곱할 필요는 없어요.
circuit이 특정 상태에 미치는 작용을
추적할 수도 있고, 많은 경우에 이것이
선호되는 옵션이 될 거예요.
이 예에서는 gate의 작용을 살펴봄으로써
circuit이 0, 0 상태에 무엇을 하는지 볼 수 있어요.
초기 상태는 Bell 상태와의
혼동을 피하기 위해 Pi 제로라고 이름 붙였는데, 0, 0이에요.
Hadamard gate를 적용하면 0+라는 상태를 얻는데, 이렇게 전개할 수 있어요.
그다음 Controlled NOT 연산이 이 상태를 Phi+ 상태로 만드는데, Controlled NOT이 표준 기저 상태에
미치는 작용을 생각하면 알 수 있어요.
나머지 세 표준 기저 상태나 다른
어떤 상태에 대해서도 같은 방식으로 할 수 있어요.
quantum circuit 다이어그램에 고전적 비트도 포함할 수 있어요.
이 다이어그램에서 보이는 것처럼
이중선으로 표시돼요.
즉, A와 B는 고전적 비트이고 X와 Y는 qubit이에요.